so the first step in this framework or
the caveats just watch out second step
is what am i what kind of innovation am
i so i've in my many years of looking at
this I've categorized innovations into
three types of innovations so one type
is consumer facing its audience is the
consumer so drugs that sell in
drugstores there are consumer facing
something like a retail medical clinic
maybe a minute clinic where you live
that's consumer facing this kind of
innovation it's saying to the customer
I'm quick I'm convenient I'm cheap and
you can reach me without any
intermediary in the way another kind of
innovation very different one is a
technology innovation let's say somebody
has a drug that can ameliorate hepatitis
or Crohn's disease or MS were AIDS
that's technology this is a burst of
science and the challenge for this
person is how do i commercialize it how
do I make sure that it gets into the
hands of the right people in a way that
still enables me to make a living
third kind of innovation very different
from the other two I call it an
integrator this is a chain of something
so the most ubiquitous kinds of
integrators or stores like McDonald's or
hotels like the Hilton chain or
department stores like Walmart
so what did these guys promise they're
not promising quick convenient like the
consumer-facing ones I certainly don't
offer dazzling technology they're not
curing the AIDS or hepatitis or
congestive heart failure so what are
they doing
they're saying we offer consistent
products and services and a relatively
low price and the way we do this is
we're a chain so if you've got a lot of
something you can develop metrics of how
the work is done you can measure how the
work is done you have a lot of scale in
a chain the economists call this
economies of scale in other words you
can buy things more cheaply because
you're buying millions of whatever
you're buying how many hundreds of
millions of pounds of potatoes does
McDonald's buy well certainly it's going
to get a better buy per pound than you
and I might get if we go into our local
supermarket so why don't we have these
categories of these three different
kinds of healthcare ventures because
analyzing their business model requires
very different kinds of elements and
we'll go back to this in detail as we go
into our cases but let me give you a
simple example of this let's say you're
running a chain of retail medical
clinics like mini clinic what kind of
CEO do you want for this do you want
somebody who has a PhD in biotechnology
anything so
do you want somebody who has a lot of
experience with running chains of
manufacturing plants I don't think so
either
what you want is somebody who has a
background in consumer facing ventures
somebody who knows how to cater to
consumers with the convenience that they
want so one of the reasons to be very
clear about the differences among the
three kinds of ventures is they require
different kinds of management the
managers of a biotechnology companies
and the managers of the MinuteClinic
they've got to be very different kinds
of people so you know lectures they're
so boring and we're gonna get done with
this soon we're gonna get to case
discussions where you'll do the talking
and I'll do the listening it's much more
interesting people really remember when
they talk they don't remember so much
when somebody else talks ever notice in
a group people say well what I said was
they remember that very vividly what you
said not so much so let's take a case
example of a venture and let's try to
classify what this venture is so let's
take a doctor and he's kind of a
computer geek doctor so he uses
computers a lot and he has written a
program that can go through the
voluminous medical literature and answer
questions that people want answers to
like my doctor says I should have a
pacemaker install very invasive
procedure but if I don't have the pace
make her install she tells me I might
die so what is it that the medical
literature tells me about the
installation of pacemakers what are the
long-term consequences after all I'm
gonna have this machine sitting inside
of me I'm kind of worried about that
what happened is five six years out does
a wear out
does it still keep functioning does it
do funny things like does it go off
erratically so this doctors figured out
a way of taking the huge medical
literature it's beyond the Ken of
anybody in fact the one of the biggest
health insurance companies in the United
States made a deal with IBM that has a
computer called Watson so Watson is
legendary for having beat the all-time
jeopardy champion because it can so
easily analyze mountains and mountains
of data and come up with the right
answer and they're trying to apply
Watson for particular uses this guy's
got a much more user-friendly version of
Watson he's tried it with a couple of
his colleagues they say it's great he
started with his friends and family they
say it's fantastic thus a typical
venture probably not a good idea to
begin with because he's invested
thousands of the hours in writing this
program without really knowing who's
going to use it or how it is that they
are going to use it but bless his heart
he's done it so what kind of venture is
this his
consumer-facing is this like mini clinic
quick convenient easy I don't see it if
you think about the kind of CEO you want
for a consumer-facing venture somebody
who comes with a consumer marketing
background like the people in Procter &
Gamble or some of these legendary
consumer marketing companies you want
that person to head this venture I don't
think so so this is a technology venture
not quite like getting a drug that will
ameliorate AIDS or hepatitis or Crohn's
disease technology ventures they they
take your breath away because they have
such novel solutions using science to
solving the problems of medicine that's
where the phd's and the propeller heads
come around even though he's a duck I
don't see it that way so we're left with
one category it's kind of a strange
category is this an integrator venture
in other words does it enable health
care to be delivered in a cheaper and
more consistent way yeah it does because
if you search the medical literature and
you find answers to questions you will
get medical practice that is more
uniform and that follows what they call
evidence-based medicine so rather than
some erratic application of medicine
you'll get more standardized ways of
doing things and when you get more
standardized ways of doing things you
know what happens errors go down when
errors go down quality goes up
and costs go down so this is believe it
or not this is an integrator venture
who's gonna buy this thing funny you
should ask
so in the United States and in many
developed countries people are
recognizing that the problem with health
care delivery is that it's too
fragmented hundreds of thousands of
doctors practicing alone thousands of
hospitals they don't talk to each other
they each do their own thing
they're all well-meaning and most of
them are phenomenally brilliant people
but that's no way to run medicine so
increasingly there's a movement to
integrate the delivery of care in the
United States so health care systems all
over the world are terribly fragmented
in the u.s. there are over 500,000
doctors who for a long time have pretty
much practice medicine as they see fit
to practice medicine thousands of
hospitals that have done the same
clinics nursing homes all very
fragmented some people who've studied
the outcomes of this health care system
say that this fragmentation is a real
problem because due to the lack of
standardization in the practice of
medicine among all these thousands and
thousands of doctors hospitals clinics
nursing homes there is not one way of
doing things because there is not one
way of doing things
people make mistakes that might be
avoided if they adhered to more
standardized protocols when they make
mistakes two things
and quality goes down costs go up so in
the US and in other developed countries
there is a movement to integrate these
providers to have systems of care rather
than one of two of five of doctors or
hospitals providing care one form of
this integration in the u.s. is called
the countable care organizations these
are systems and they consist of
hospitals and doctors and nursing homes
and clinics and urgent care centers
essentially everything that you need if
you need medical care and they provided
out of one system that's networked and
talks to each other and all the
providers know what everybody else is
doing the accountable care organizations
they're called a ce o--'s with their
initials they might be very interested
in this program after all this program
searches through the medical literature
and it comes up with what the medical
literature has found to be the best
answer to a specific kind of problem in
fact I think that'd be real interest in
that and real interested for their
providers so that's medical speak for
their doctors and nurses that therapists
all the great people who are in the
healthcare system and they might even be
interested for their patients so the
patient I talked about earlier who says
you want to put a pacemaker in me I want
to know how this works how it works in
the long term with the positive side is
with the negative
so it is okay so we've got the a zero as
a customer the ACO is an integrator and
this medical program enables integration
so what kind of person do we want to
head this kind of new venture hold that
thought
we'll come back to this question in a
little while but before we even address
this question we want to figure out
whether this thing is viable or not